hello grammarians we're talking about
vowel shifting in irregular verbs which
is gonna sound a little weird but bear
with me to review what a vowel is super
quick a vowel is any sound that your
mouth can make while your tongue isn't
touching your lips or your teeth or the
roof of your mouth basically and in
English we render vowels in the
following way
a e I owe you and sometimes Y or as it
is commonly pronounced how that uh that
parts not true but here is what's true
is that you produce vowels from
different parts of your mouth you can
produce a vowel in front of your mouth
you can produce it in the center of your
mouth you can produce it all the way
back in your throat and what does this
have to do with irregular verbs I'm so
glad you asked let's draw a chart so I'm
going to put three things on this chart
the present the past and the past
perfect which is when you're talking
about something in the past that is
completed and we form that in English by
combining that verb with have so have
walked have said have done now in most
cases with most regular verbs the past
perfect and the past form are the same
the same thing but in some very rare
cases and that's why we're talking about
these they're different and let's begin
with the first one in the present tense
we say I sing in the past tense we would
say she sang and in the past perfect you
would say they have sung so it's weird
right because the vowel changes this
vowel sound it actually bounces along
your mouth it goes from front to middle
to back as you go further and further
back in time which i think is really
cool a same thing with the word drink in
the present tense it's I drink in the
past tense it's I drank and in the past
perfect it's I had drunk there are other
verbs that follow this formula too like
ring ring rang rung for ringing a bell
but for the rest of this we're just
going to talk about verbs where the past
and the past perfect are the same and
there's still a vowel shift going on
between the
and the past so if you take a word like
when the present tense is win the past
tense is won and the past perfect is
also one we had won the game we won the
game
so that vowel shift goes from a to a the
verb to find so in the present tense its
find and in the past and past perfect
it's found it goes from ie to ow
sit become sat sneak become snuck and
run becomes ran and run is a weird one
because the past perfect form of run is
run he had run not he had ran and those
are some of the front to back sound
shifts it at or it or I tau that you
will encounter when you're learning
irregular verbs in English you can learn
anything Dave it out